when I don't open this yet now can we  have some more of the nominees Oh wrong  glass decide the nominees for the best  story and screenplay based on factual  material or material not previously  published or produced ah Perry Chayefsky  for the hospital a Leo Petri and ego  Pierrot for investigation of a citizen  above suspicion Andy and Dave Lewis for  Clute Herman Rocha for summer of 42  Penelope gilead for Sunday Bloody Sunday  and the winner is  the winner is paddy Chayefsky  I'm afraid I feel exactly like Ernest ID  me it's a special privilege and  especially gratifying this particular  award considering the very high caliber  of all the others nominations in this  category and I must respect we want to  thank all of them very very much indeed  thank you